the big story at the moment actually is
the kyle rittenhouse trial now i don't
want to get into all of the specifics of
the event that happened now almost a
year and a half ago
but we are going to link to a video that
we did that's a pretty decent recap of
everything that happened related uh to
kyle
the shooting what was going on in
kenosha a little bit of the history it
involved some video from tucker
carlson's show where they did a really
nice recap of everything that was going
on there but i thought for the purposes
of today because so much of this is
breaking right now i didn't want to get
too much into the history of the story
but i know a lot of you wanted to hear
my opinions on it uh so first i want to
talk really about the way the media has
treated kyle
uh more than anything else because so
much of our the disconnect that we have
in society and as i always talk about
that sort of chasm between what we see
with our own eyes online and what the
mainstream media will allow us to talk
about that really is the biggest issue
that we have in society and this story
is a perfect example of it uh kyle
happens to be a young white kid so
obviously in the mainstream media eyes
no matter what happened even if his life
was being threatened and he was about to
be pummeled by a mob or he was about to
be shot or whatever
he's the bad guy in their view now i
don't really care about narrative i care
about truth so if kyle was out there
just murdering people murdering
protesters and shooting people not in
self-defense of course like it's not
even a question it's so stupid to even
have to talk about it of course then he
should be tried and convicted he should
have his right to a fair trial and
everything else
but there were so many people
in the media who over the last year and
a half were immediately condemning him
damning him to hell and basically
condemning not only him but white people
in general and young people and
everything else so tucker crossing did a
really nice recap of some of the stuff
that the media has done related to all
of this last night take a look
but you know never know any of this from
watching the coverage of the trial
nbc news for example just ran this
thoroughly dishonest headline quote
shooting victim at written house trial
said he thought he was going to die
what the article didn't mention it seems
kind of relevant
the shooting victim was pointed a loaded
gun at the boy who shot him
so they're liars you knew that in this
case they have to lie if they didn't
they'd be forced to admit that they were
wrong from the very beginning in case
you've forgotten this is what they were
telling you all last year about kyle
rittenhouse
ridden house is basically what you would
have had in a school shooter he's a 17
year old kid he shouldn't have had a gun
he crossed state lines to supposedly
protect property no he was going out to
shoot people you see the 17 year old who
was radicalized by trumpism took his
ar-15 to kenosha and became a killer a
17-year-old kid from out of state a boy
from out of state
drives up to the state with an ar-15
around his neck
shoots and kills a couple of people uh
shooting wildly running around uh acting
like
rent-a-cop and it's not good that a
17-year-old vigilante
arguably a domestic terrorist picked up
a rifle drove to a different state to
shoot people
yeah he drove to a different state to
shoot people that's what happened really
open up your brain let's pour some more
lies in it
actually in point of fact kyle
rittenhouse went to kenosha to clean up
the filth left by the rioting biden
voters the child molester included turns
out the morning of the shooting kyle
rittenhouse was videotaped cleaning
anarchist graffiti off the walls of a
local high school that seems like good
citizenship actually
naturally elected democrats denounced
him as a racist ayanna presley described
written house as a quote white
supremacist domestic terrorist echoing
the msnbc morning show elon omar did the
same joe biden on the basis of no
evidence whatsoever called the 17 year
old quote a white supremacist
now for the record
the men written how shot were all white
kind of a funny kind of white supremacy
there
it turns out that like so much of the
hyperventilating moral outrage we suffer
through every single day the tale of
kyle rittenhouse is a myth
okay so that's just a great job by
tucker and his team that's why i wanted
to show you that full two minute clip
there uh if you want more on the
specifics of exactly what happened that
day again we have a link to our video
which was from september 2020 if i'm not
mistaken uh so you can see actually like
the full sort of chronology of what
exactly happened and that kyle had a gun
pointed to his face and that this was a
kid who was trying not to instigate he
was trying to de-escalate but watch that
and make a decision for that on your own
i should mention also that robert barnes
who is my friend and who has been on the
show this show several times he's one of
kyle's lawyers so we'll get him back on
hopefully in the next couple weeks to
discuss and now i want to show you two
videos from the trial today because this
is all unfolding in the in the last
little bit um the first one's actually
sort of hard to watch so this is kyle
on the stand himself defending himself
not something that he has to do this is
something that the defense decided that
they would do
and he broke down while he was
giving testimony look over my shoulder
and
mr rosenbaum
mr rosenbaum was now running
from
my right side
and
i was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and there were
there were
three
people right there
whatever
you can just relax for a minute sir uh
we're going to take a break about uh 10
minutes and please don't talk about the
case during the break what read watch or
listen to any economy
okay so that's obviously you know kind
of hard to watch i just want to back up
for a second and talk a little bit about
those cnn and msnbc
commentators contributors blowhards
liars bloviators whatever you want to
call them who are calling that kid a
white supremacist and joe biden who
called him a white supremacist there's
no evidence literally no evidence that
he's a white supremacist there is no
social media posts anywhere that he's a
white supremacist or anything like that
this is what they do with everything
that first guy in that compilation we
showed you who said that he's a 17 year
old white kid like the perfect you know
mass shooter it's like they're they're
imagining a reality instead of looking
at the reality that's right in front of
them these people are actually dangerous
the amount of people that they are they
are instigating to hate people for no
reason other than the color of their
skin while they call the rest of us
racist anyway if you if you watch the
full video you see that he was clearly
trying to defend himself this was not
someone who was out there to try to hurt
himself now maybe he should not have
been out there maybe too many people are
getting involved in all sorts of things
right now and we've watched cities burn
and everything's kind of screwy
but this this kid is not a cold-blooded
murderer uh he was defending himself
look watch the video yourself again it's
in the link down below and if you think
that if he had done nothing he would be
alive you're probably wrong he was most
likely about to be killed or pummeled or
whatever it might be